[Music]
thank you to the good people wired ice
quantifying our existence as human
beings through digital analytics making
us what we are just a bunch of ones and
zeros let's really put together for us
shall we let's shout this is what
happens when you google John Cena about
146 million results in point 69 seconds
to have any sense of that at all John
any said that means nothing like I don't
have any sort of point of reference it
seems like it seems like the car has a
lot of miles on it I'll tell you that
one section that comes up is people also
ask can you answer these questions I
will was John Cena in the military no
almost almost
I didn't go as far as to actually
signing up because the weekend I was
supposed to go a friend was like hey man
I'm training to be a professional
wrestler in Orange County would you like
to come with me I was like I'll give
that a shot
okay does John Cena still wrestle well
now that's an interesting question
because fans of the WWE have universally
agreed that I can't wrestle in the first
place
so for the past 17 years I've been
making an existence on a program where
the nucleus is wrestling without
wrestling insane or just super smart
this is what happens when you google
keegan-michael key about 11 million and
500 results come up in point six six
seconds so why did it take quicker for
you well it's because it's some hundreds
of million people less oh one section
that comes up is that people also ask
can you answer these questions are
keegan-michael key and Jordan Peele
still friends that is to assume that we
were friends in the first place which
which we are which you should assume we
are friends of perfect like we used to
live together I don't get to see him as
often as I want to cuz you know he's
married he has a domestic life a child
SUV the whole nine yards and when I say
SUV it's just a fancy way of saying
minivan here's a minivan here's the next
question is keegan-michael key in US I
hope so I hope that lana knew
and in your heart and in your spirit I
have to plead the fifth according to
Google people who search for you also
search for these five people can you
guess who they are
yes I can don knotts abraham lincoln
ulysses s grant hmm franklin roosevelt
and robert oppenheimer
rey mysterio no I can't believe I forgot
that one rock Lesnar both of them are
trending by the way oh they're both
strange congratulations
Ronda Rousey I didn't necessarily make
that connection
The Undertaker okay all right this seems
very WWE related I'm Dwayne Johnson Oh
pumpkin you know right I thought thunk
it on my five wow I mean I'm not in
touch what are the net likes okay all
right all right okay so according to
Google people who searched for you me
also search for these five other people
just gonna go out on a limb and say and
I'm probably wrong on this one I'm gonna
go with a little fellow you may have
heard of named Jordan Peele all right so
we're gonna say Jordan Peele I also
think right now because I'm still
technically a newly Wed people may be
searching for elke Elysa key or ELISA
coulier's II know is it that's three
names who are all the same person so
that's four that's four and then after
that whatever Viggo Mortensen Eric tur
was in Lord of the Rings Jordan Peele I
got that right watch this one - oh no
reason for me to that loud except for
that it was genuine surprise Billy
Eichner makes okay all right mm-hmm yep
mm-hmm
oh that okay all right Donald Glover
number four so I'm two for two two for
four don't do that an Eric Andre oh he's
pretty great right Eric and others
contest no I definitely wasn't expecting
the Lion King connection which is weird
because it's only the most popular movie
that was ever made so why would I not
guess somebody this is a Google Trends
graph of your name searched over time
can I explain each labelled point a is
May 30th of 2016
oh that was obviously a day that will
live in personal infamy for the entire
day and I mean from midnight to midnight
I suffered from explosive diarrhea it
was that day ah well yes oh it was also
the wonderful happy filled day for many
across the world as I returned to the
global phenomenon known as WWE which
caused explosive no no no had it before
that okay gotcha for an interesting
return all right in April of 2018 mm-hmm
that was a really was that uh wait a
second I took a beer up my butt that's
exactly what happened so you know to
combat repeated cases of explosive
diarrhea what did I do
of pills there enema as blockers was
released in April 2000 18 Oh
shiver me timbers okay this is a Google
Trends graph of my name keegan-michael
key searched over times once that yours
is so more awesome than one there's
really April of 2015 is a high point I'm
going to
No when are the Emmys September or the
other thing that could be is that I
performed with the leader of the free
world Barack Obama at the White House
Correspondents Dinner I think that might
be it Lindsay be be is September of 2018
September of last year the entire month
the entire month of last year you know I
don't want to be too rebellious what the
hell happened in late April 2016 why are
we not looking at that nothing twice was
released really interesting
I am DB which is a completely accurate
site has listed all of your twisted if
your personal quotes you can't see me
word life the champ is here where the
fighting or spittin my discipline is
unforgiving you want some come get some
are they forgetting any well if you go
by the noises of the current talking
John Cena WWE licensed all no because I
believe I say five things and those are
the five and if you hit the doll
besides ouch or ow those are the five
things that it actually says well look
at okay so there are five thousand six
hundred and ninety-three images of me on
Getty when sorted by oldest boy
don't worry the selfish in my past made
me sad that's the oldest look at what's
on my wrist it's a bracelet of some sort
I seldom if ever wear bracelet jewelry
other than my watches but that is
interesting that account was a good idea
my friend I can tell you one thing right
now that shirt says the word Detroit on
it that I can guarantee you that's an
episode it was a that was a target as a
Motor City ring as a Motor City friend
or t appreciate ya John these you three
most viewed videos on YouTube do I know
what they are
oh boy let me just just go speculate
here John Cena doing something with WWE
John Cena doing something with wve John
Cena doing something with deputy UE Oh
John Cena and Brock Lesnar get into a
brawl that clears the entire locker room
on Raw April 2012 WWE John Cena Batista
Richard Rey Mysterio about in Randy
Orton Jerry show on Tribute to the
Troops
in December 2008 that has to do with WWE
John Cena and AJ Lee kiss after the
victory over Dolph Ziggler in November
2012 and that has something to do with
WWE combined their 35:35 my goodness not
combined 135 235 109 106 yeah you think
this YouTube thing know that okay
alright we collected all the comments
from those sets of videos and made word
clouds John here are some of the words
we noticed mm-hmm wow it love fight love
fan slap la hint slap his husband
beast Lesnar okay can I explain them
love why would it be there because
although you know I project a angular
and pretty much straightforward exterior
there's a lot of love on the inside I
think I think the web understands that
above all entities hi is I believe that
it's Japanese for it before yes you got
me guessing on that one slap because
it's what you should do to me right now
for not knowing no no don't that's not
an actual no if I slapped you I just be
hurting myself all right
Keegan these are your three most viewed
videos on YouTube do you know what they
are we're gonna go with substitute
teacher can't feel we're gonna go with
east/west bowl key and Peele and we're
gonna go with the greatness we're gonna
go with the White House Correspondents
Dinner my performance with President
Barack Obama let's see mm-hmm that's
your teacher right all right yeah
feeling good nice lovely blast from the
past
epic Rap Battles hit me oh I got two out
of three that's actually that's really
good I don't know why I'm so excited but
I don't win anything
but I love the Gandhi vs. Martin Luther
King epic Rap Battles cuz it's always
nice to be able to feel like you can
have a little bit of fun and educate the
masses as well yeah you don't I mean
yeah look at myself Gandhi stache
kicking here are some words that we
noticed in word they made we're in a
word cloud and here are some of the
words of notice the biggest word that
smack in the middle which is Aaron or a
a Ron is pretty self-explanatory it's
something that is yelled at me across
streets every single day of my life
where is ay-ay-ron right now
no Aron huh do you know that you've
literally ruined the name Ayers oh yeah
I'm not ruined it you have redefined
than it yes I apologized to every human
being I meet named Aaron pronounced
women whose names are spelled er I am
come up to me which I found very strange
and I'm like you mean I ran because your
name is ear in that we can have a
conversation but a a Ron is you know I
think it's probably the thing that I am
most known for it is a moniker it's a
shame this is you've changed the English
language that's awesome you've changed
it changed the length mess mess why
would mess be a word would have been way
more appropriate for me injury
John we found this Chrome extension
dedicated to you where did you find it
my dresser it's not mine anyway one
installed each time someone opens a tab
they will see a new HD John see an image
thoughts on this well I have some
questions first what is it is a Chrome
extension what I think it is Chrome
easily got a browser of course it is
that's what I was talking it's exactly
what you think it is of course any
thoughts on this so why would you do
this to yourself why I you want to
search for anything on the Internet and
your result is me my goodness that's a
is it there's a whole world out there
don't take off the goggles break away
from the shackles use the internet for
it it's for peace harmony and
togetherness that's connecting us all
that's what it's for
yeah exactly so Keegan these are your
top 10 most popular reddit posts okay
let me see here and this is your most up
voted one Jordan Peele in chemo kill
reunited after the Oscars can I describe
this moment
yeah right here on the bots to plan a
big one on Jordan it's just utter
unabashedly not really what it is is
it's me Georgey going if you look like
behind me there's different wasps I was
just gonna say that's what I don't sound
to you that many Christopher Walken call
in for more cowbell
John these are your top rated movies on
Rotten Tomatoes
that I mean get ready can you explain
your role in all of these Bumblebee yes
I was a conflicted force of the military
thinking that transformers are here to
end our locust like existence only to
find out that some of them have friendly
personalities and some of them have
angry personalities and a movie ensues
around it toward a pharmacy I was a
cyclist who is obsessed that I did not
possess a rage yet I was possessing it's
large amounts of rage as I would inject
myself with cheetah blood and I was
accused of being a cheetah when I was a
human not a cheetah I just had cheetah
blood inside of me trainwreck I was a
confused toxically masculine boyfriend
of Amy Schumer who when brought to light
with serious questions of like where do
we go next in our relationship just
continued to go in a downward spiral
with not knowing exactly who he is
blockers a protective dad raising an
athletic girl almost wishing she was a
boy who eventually will do anything to
save his daughter from making the
biggest mistake of her life including a
pilsner enema the next movie coming out
that should be on here is playing with
fire where I play a rugged leader like
superintendent who is flanked by the
comedic chops of keegan-michael key and
and realizes that there's more to life
than fighting fires when I challenge
myself with the biggest challenge to
date babysitting three kids he's flanked
by my chops mm-hmm
Tinka these are the top hashtags on
Instagram with your name okay
so we have a hashtag keegan-michael key
hashtag keegan-michael Keys which means
that there must be a clone of me out
there someplace
hashtag keegan-michael key fans hashtag
keegan-michael key
ke why E which is an interesting
spelling you would still pronounce the
same way now then hashtag keegan-michael
key is really nice in person and very
considerate
he would bear robbing if he was a bird
so let's go over that again
hashtag keegan-michael key is really
nice in person and very considerate he
would be a Robin if he was a bird this
could is this this may be the longest
hashtag written and you're right
also I appreciate you saying I would be
a robin robin robin redbreast
I really appreciate that the Robin is
the state bird of my home state of
Michigan so I really appreciate the fact
that you would would call me a Robin I
feel like somebody's actually done their
uh their due diligence and their
homework there Roger that
well uh thank you guys for really
putting me in my place and telling me
exactly where I stand amongst the
culture of the internet I am so much
more charged to attack my day and by
that I mean we're in the 36th floor of a
hotel and I want to sprint towards that
window to see if it breaks tonight oh
the ground fast at negative 9.8 meters
per second squared I'm not gonna do this
so they grabbed my camera oh you're not
you're not going to know I'm certainly
not gonna do that in there that's right
it's going package that away and just
maybe years from now and a therapist's
office discuss what you guys have done
to me so thanks guys appreciate it